so here we are in my lessons
all right let me just stop you there
yeah so i i just it's it's interesting
to note some people may not realize it
that
uh you can see that there's 14
new words in eastward
or 17
17
is gonna is a sweet spot it's a
moderately difficult number you know
it's not really easy it's a little it's
17 so you have 17 new words in there
that you haven't opened this before
right number nine
yeah yeah i think i just started it and
then just started okay all right yeah do
you wanna do this one we can do that or
you can do a number ten it doesn't
matter to me
okay cool let's do this one okay
yeah i don't even
remember what's in here
is this the beginning no this isn't the
first page
well
you know what that says
all right
time for me to pronounce
yeah now you know what just for fun
click on the audio symbol there
okay but i've i've got the um
no okay then don't do it then don't do
it but i was just going to say that
again that because the many stories are
time stamped
therefore when you're in sentence mode
of course you can hear the natural voice
for that sentence
and in terms of getting the rhythm of
the language i mean i'm doing this now
for uh you know persian and arabic it
just can help you because you kind of
hear it then you try to you know imitate
it here yeah imitate it
so uh not that that's i could i and i
could always i could disconnect this um
so people could hear it
sure
okay it's just
gonna all right
so this should work now
um
so if you were to say that five ten
times first of all you know the ooh and
the is always an issue so here it's ooh
right
i mean it's just to try and get the sort
of uh
um intonation so i i just something that
i recommend to people
that because we do have
not only the translation for the
individual sentences but we also have
the the natural audio timestamp so it's
a good place to work on your
pronunciation your intonation and also
your reading speed
because after you hear it once try and
read it at the same speed as the
narrative
because it might sound fast to you
because you're an early stage in the
language but eventually that's going to
be normal speed for you yeah
no definitely i um that's why
some of the past uh exercises that we've
done i hadn't actually
like heard
heard it pronounced um
so it makes it really challenging to to
try to just
come out without yourself without
listening to it and that's also why
listening back on many stories one
through eight multiple times has
i think really helped start to
internalize those pronunciations
okay
now if you go on to the next page andre
should disappear in other words you
don't have to i actually i i do have my
um link reader settings set to not oh
cannot okay then you might want to
remove andre because yeah unless you
want that i mean that's the french
version from andrew i just haven't um
gone through this one so okay i actually
no but there is a choice there i i never
know quite what to do but if you have a
name
but it is the french version of andrew
uh-huh so should you save that as a word
or not is that a word known a word
learned or not it's it's i subjected x
yeah i hit the x to ignore
um
it sounds to me to not
unless it's like a um
um for example like a a proper noun that
is a famous place
right that might be something that i
would say but names i haven't been
so so i think the important thing is
that the statistics are for us as
learners
and we can do with what then what we
want it's not for showing off to other
people if you want to have these french
forms of english names as known words
you do so if you want to ignore them as
proper names you can do so it doesn't
matter no rules no rules you choose your
links and your known and learned words
the way that it works best for you
exactly
great
so maybe pronounce that sentence all
right
okay so right away the reason why it's
going to listen to that is you have the
u
and the u
so say
okay
you notice the difficulty there is once
you've hit the u
then the next o
there's a lingering effect so it
actually
over time you get better and better it's
the same with the nasal sounds it's
like they all come together you can get
them confused so it's just a matter of
training the brain
and the more you hear it the more you
pronounce it the better the brain gets
it doing it otherwise then the you can
trip over your tongue as you're doing it
until you get to
develop those habits
in my experience it's not it's also
training the the tongue too you know it
has to get comfortable yeah
the tongue but you since you have unless
you're smarter than i am you cannot
really control what your tongue does in
other words
so it's just that the brain eventually
starts sending the right signals
okay
did i ever tell you the story that when
i was young my father could wiggle his
ears
and i couldn't no i wanted to learn to
wiggle my ears now if you can't wiggle
your ears it's very hard to send a
message to your ears to move
but i used to sit there watching tv at
the age of eight and i'd go i want my
ears to move and now i can wiggle my
ears
can you see that yeah i can wiggle my
ears can you see them wiggling
you're tiny on the screen right oh yeah
okay anyway the point is it is
extraordinary
what with will we can make our brain do
so if you develop this habit of hearing
and hearing and hearing and saying and
saying it gradually
the tongue is going to
start doing what it's supposed to do
maybe
i pay myself to wiggle my ears too there
you go that's very useful very useful
thing
all right okay do this one again or next
page next page okay
no well okay but that's fine that's fine
i i wouldn't get too hung up about the
guttural r it'll gradually get better
um
i find that the intonation is more
important
and of course
a couple of things there that for people
who are watching of course we have anami
as a friend without an e and unami with
an e at the end is a female so
me
uh
often is used for girlfriend
where wherever we say girlfriend in
english and francis they put me so if a
guy has a girlfriend he says mapatita me
because otherwise you have to go monami
right because in french is another thing
you can't have
ma followed by an a you wouldn't have
mommy so even if it's ami with an o at
the end like a female friend
if it's my friend mon ami
you can't tell if it's a male or a
female
if it's just spoken do you understand
what i'm saying so oh really so then i
would so you don't say mommy
no
me means mommy mom
i wouldn't have uh known that because no
i guessed that because
ma like my feminine
right and like following the other rule
with the liaison like you can't have the
a you know one word ending with an a and
then the next word starting with the a i
would assume that you would do the m
apostrophe
i'm trying to remember because i don't
know my french rules i just know what
i'm used to
and uh i'm trying to think of
i another example
uh
so there's mesmes but you know
mesa me is not a problem
you don't know if it's masculine or
feminine or mixed right but unless you
read it but i'm thinking about can't
immediately think of a feminist word
that begins with a what's a feminine
word the beginning
yeah so monavo anterior okay about here
is feminine you don't say ma i want you
you say monavanteo if you
i guess i should stay away from all the
always and never statements when it
comes to language learning right it's
because they don't want to have the ma
they can't have two a's together it
sounds
and i was just having this conversation
about why they do that and in spanish
and i think it's similar because it's
the way it sounds
like you'll take a word like agua or
alma which ends with a so you think
would be feminine but they're masculine
and i think it's right
to the a
way smoother on the ear and these
romance languages then
right like that's really awkward right
uh yeah it's the same in french then
except in the case of l
they use the apostrophe
love onto you so
but
you wouldn't be able to tell me but with
my it's monami or
my girlfriend
is right okay so here we have this guy
who's gonna kick cook food for his new
girlfriend and his girlfriend is his
potitani
and her name is sarah right okay
you are you're
you know the story by heart you're like
i've heard this story 30 times in five
languages okay
great
uh andre
okay now listen to it and say it again
whoa
exactly now you're trying to go at that
speed with that internet
is that the natural or is that the oh
that's the text to speech that's a text
to speech can you get them why is that
now that you found me
ah oh you know
just this morning and a call um
one of our developers were saying i
think like the time stamps for the
um sentence mode needed a little tweak
so
okay but let's listen to it again let's
listen to this again
this way no no no no from uh
that's
it's hard to tell before she speaks like
a machine at any rate i recommend that
you do some some uh working on these
where you listen to the sentence
and try and
nail
first of all the intonation and the
speed and don't don't worry about what
you mangle
just try to imitate the intonation
and and when you get the intonation
you'll find a lot of other stuff falls
into place
okay
but you can read it slowly now read it
slowly one more time
okay the r at the end is always a not
pronounced so andre
cuisine
and it doesn't drag on this is not r is
not one of those liaison there's an
exception to everything
on the
you got to be careful in english we have
a tendency to put the uh the stress on
the first syllable whereas in french
it's
okay
i think i know what this is yeah
supermarket
okay
yeah that's the natural voice yeah that
sounds okay now uh
you see it says felix
what do you think that means
like
make his way
okay highlight that phrase
oh
now bear in mind that the translation it
may not
like the person who
created the french version
decided not to say he goes to the
grocery store and decided to say he goes
shopping at the grocery store so that
the the translations are not going to be
word for word 100
so is it
is feliko is that a
an expression to mean to go shopping
now it's funny
in quebec they say magazines sometimes
in france they sometimes say fairly
shopping
okay
but fairly courses fairly courses you
like your regular shopping it's not
magazine might be or failure shopping
might be to go buy a new you know blouse
or shoes or something
but uh felice is your regular shopping
you gotta go to the supermarket that's
where you go for family tools
so question then yeah
redundant to say felix
and to say oh supermache no you might go
to the grocery store the sugar mache is
in fact not the grocery store again i
apologize for the translation it's the
supermarket right but um so you have le
pca is the grocery store
yeah le pca the spice imagine it was the
spice store apc
okay
okay okay so
it's not redundant no and uh marche is i
mean that didn't exist when i lived in
france in this in the 60s
so and say
right
so it's good to practice these
especially to get that you sound not to
make it on its own but to make it in the
middle of a sentence this is it's going
to take but a month from now you'll do
with no difficulty so you just got to
keep working at it and and the other
thing
that's maybe not uh
you know
as in many languages
he goes
in a way doesn't mean he goes to the
grocery store it means he is going to
go shopping the grocery store to me ilva
is like the future tense yeah affair but
it also means he goes in vapers he's it
has that sense of he's about to go to
the supermarket to me it does anyway
anyway maybe not who knows everything is
not necessarily a hundred percent okay
so give me the whole sentence here okay
perfect yeah no actually it is he goes
to he goes shopping at the supermarket
but it could also mean
cool domain he's going to go shopping
tomorrow
but that's not what it says and so you
it's not required to specify where he's
going shopping but no no i'm going
shopping but it's cool to me and we'll
have some
french speakers who might correct me but
to me fellai course suggests you know
your regular food shopping uh your
regular regular shopping of some kind so
we don't regularly go shopping for
clothing but we regularly go shopping
for food yeah so
okay
by the way a good strategy when speaking
which you did
it's a bit of a mouthful to say the
whole sentence so you you went in
and i think that's a very good strategy
to get the pronunciation so it doesn't
matter that you take a breather
and then really focus on the
pronunciation within each of those
phrases that's good strategy it's a it's
the same learning strategy i apply to
pretty much everything which is like
something is you got a big task and it's
really overwhelming you just gotta break
it down into smaller parts absolutely
one slice at a time
the salami approach
okay
all right so
i have not come across these words
before basket
yeah i
would not recognize that
so carte
okay so it sounds like
is this
word used in multiple different contexts
well you know i i to be perfectly honest
it's not a word that i use
but the word shayo is used for cart in
different scenarios
so uh whoever i'm sure this person knows
that the shopping cart is known as
ashayo it's not an important word to
know
uh unless you weren't shopping and you
need someone to
you know find you a shopping cart but
but yeah that's i mean we identify the
the sha the car you know that's
obviously a related word card
uh-huh yeah but very different
if you would never remember that word i
don't think it matters
okay so let's hear the whole yeah and in
english of course it's like you know
there's that saying you're you're you're
sure yet awaits you so
that's why i'm thinking like does this
mean something else you're sure yet what
what was that dariet awaits you
oh yeah yeah like you're you're almost
like your show first oh yeah yeah yeah i
i don't know if the chariot like the
roman chariot if that's also how they
say that in french those are just not
words that i've used but if i if you see
the charlo you should be able to figure
out what it means sure yeah yeah that's
true
okay let's hear the sounds
very good
oh
she misses the vegetable section
[Music]
is this a
common phrase here
yes passes by
okay so
or walks by side
would you say that's a good translation
to save
well
he misses the vegetable section i don't
know why the original english was
written that way
but pasakote is he walks by he walks by
he passes by
yeah
okay now cote just means side that's
what it means okay so i can save it like
this yeah but akote is also a good i
would say
all right
next to nearby well it can be but it
also means beside
okay next or next two next two yeah it
passes next you know
that's good next to nearby yep
beside that's another good one yeah
great
now if you if you take the phrase
oops
he walks past marks past yeah that's
good
okay so and that pass passes i mean it's
almost like the english
yeah
no
classes yeah
now do real like real if you click on
rio
it's
there you got to be a little imaginative
but it's the shelf
is it all of these other things too it
can be a ray beam and stuff like that
but i always like to choose the one
that's relevant to whatever i'm studying
and here's the shell for the section
absolutely that's a that's an
interesting one um
because yeah that can
create i mean it makes sense right array
it's something yeah
it's
i mean multiple things because
in this state for me it seems like a
false cognate if it just means shelf
right but if i can think of like array
or right it's array is a way to think of
it yeah
okay
so i there i would take sorry go back to
the dictionaries again
oops well no
okay but we missed it check manage
popular go to popular translations
so this is the different translations
that people have chosen i would have
taken vegetables masculine plural
because that gives me more information i
see yeah sometimes those hints like they
are i can see how they're really helpful
and sometimes they
i think it's just that they
yeah
no you see where it says
right
yeah
what does do he own tell you about the
word
that it is
masculine correct okay
okay
now you know the thing about all these
is is the the the many stories are a
place for training
and so listening repetitively is good
training reading it is good training but
also going through it sentence by
sentence and trying to get as close as
possible to the intonation of the
natural voice is very good training not
just for
the the sort of substance of this story
but to get your brain your tongue and
everything working to get closer to
french intonation and one other thing if
you click on uh
you know he'll pass he passes right so
click on that
and then go to uh
search reversal verb conjugation one of
the dictionaries there
down below one
yeah
so one thing i like to do from time to
time
is look up the conjugation
of the verbs
because it's and you have to do it over
and over and over again because so you
notice that
and
have this are the same right
and uh yeah that's always how it is
uh not always like
but it is in this case
and and i always take this as an
opportunity to review the imperfect the
future i just look at them
whether i'm in arabic or whatever
and uh slowly slowly slowly all these
different tenses they start to kind of
penetrate right yeah so we see that in
the in the uh
imperfect the gerund two are the same
but elon l is is different again right
you look at it and it makes a bit of an
impression let's uh get out of that and
let's go to the previous sentence
go back one
okay click on
same thing you to do the same thing with
that yeah go to the uh
context reverso
check manage that context reversal
conjugation
yeah no no no you didn't go to the
conjugation one you went to the other
context reversal you gotta be a little
careful there's context reversal
dictionary which is also very good but
then there's the conjugation one yeah
this is like a really common word in
french yeah
so you'll hear here you see that jour
and two have the same endings s
but e and l have no s
got me there
okay
so i just recommend and you can scroll
down the conjugations you'll see that
the full conjugation of the word
paw is there
so
it's it's too much information for you
to absorb
it's just good to know that it's there
and that at any time you can go in and
check the conjugation yeah and i i do
think i need to um
get into this more the stage that i'm at
now because like i'm i'm getting
familiar you know i can easily recognize
like that's a that's a future or that's
a present tense or a future tense
right or a past tense verb but then how
do i
uh
how do i produce that is a little you
know a little bit more challenging and
then especially these other tenses right
the imperfect subjunctive right
i must say that that i wouldn't worry
about producing it now
sure i just think that if you regularly
review you see you look at the
conjugation table you get back into the
text you're doing a lot of listening and
at some point
at some point you'll start producing and
you'll be surprised how much your brain
has picked up
exactly and i wanted to share with
everyone um i mean everyone uses link
differently and
encourage everyone to find what works
best for them
um i was chatting with a friend who's
been on link for four years
and he's got over like 50 000 words in
russian and he was saying that in the
beginning when he is first
um saving uh meanings for words
he will and like this is a great example
he will actually um since this is a
present tense verb in this context that
we're looking at
um he's actually going to take the time
to save the entire
um
the entire present tense right
conjugations
he has them all in his
uh
like and right here like and he's
actually oh yeah it's time to
um but he would put them
you know what i would uh recommend that
people not do that
because this is supposed to be the hint
i would put it in the notes area
oh and you know perhaps i'm sorry i
think that is what he did i think so
because whatever you do to the
dictionary other people are going to see
so
the notes is for you there that makes
more sense yeah
yeah so he will like take this extra
time and he said you know it's
definitely an extra time
um commitment in the beginning
as time goes on you don't
you don't that's a very good idea that's
a very good idea
[Music]
you